I only use the scales from the belly of
the Python right up the middle so it
kind of wastes a lot of Python because I
only use the middle part the middle
belly the best cuts but I think it's
what makes the brand special mgq style
editor will Welch I'm here at Barney's
with the legendary Don see if done let's
get right into the game with can you
just like take us through a just on
count I sort of reinvented the style of
baseball caps with the Python brand
right the strap gold buckle and the tab
take us back to the history of the hats
like the spark of the idea I was
inspired by the buck 50 cap the buck 50
cap was a cap that was like the
quintessential baller cap of the late
80s and 90s for drug dealers in Chicago
yes there were no rappers at the
Dutcher's television they were sold in
liquor stores and convenience stores
it was mostly seamstresses from that
local neighborhood they would glue fake
Python fake snake skin on top of the
brim and then sew a strap on the back
and the guys who could afford a baseball
cap that had fake Python and a fake
Python strap on the back with drug
dealers because they were 150 dollars
right in the 80s that's how they got the
name buck 50 Chicago in the 80s this was
like a local custom thing right it's
definitely a Chicago thing you know
different parts of the country have
heard about the buck 50 but it really
hasn't gotten much shine so I'm happy to
kind of help educate the youngsters
today about the buck 50 and its history
in my city and you know put a modern
twist on it now you can buy one at
Barney yeah the new buck 50 working on
different clothing projects I would
always try to figure out man
gonna bring a book 50 back so I tried to
sell the idea not for money nobody want
to bite it so I said let me just make
these and unfortunately a few of my
friends wore them and I would kind of
turn it into a brand I love this game
I'll tell you one thing I laugh at is
like it's like a guy where old buck 52
some of the kids will say hey that's a
fake Don C hat and I'm like no that's
the original inspiration of my idea so
done guys with a lot of different
personal style wear your hats but what's
the key for somebody who's like
considering going this direction maybe
somebody's never won Python skin before
how do you pull it off maybe start with
a black on black
that's usually the entry level after
that you want to go for a second or
third you want to spice up your life so
you want to live with a little color or
maybe even a metallic skin sometimes
some guys flake the Python is hanging
over the brim where guys they are really
like that I think that's part of what
makes the brand unique because no two
hats are exactly the same but some guys
even say I don't like the order on the
internet because I like to go to the
store and it'll be like the same cat but
they want to pick the one day one I love
that because I'm a consumer like that
hey this shirt the collar is a little
different than that one I noticed the
inconsistencies in product so I think
it's cool where a product that's
purposely inconsistent you can go to the
store and drive your sales person crazy
get this kit for every hat out of the
stockroom until you find the one that
calls your name absolutely
gotta be brave the binge or Python burns
it's okay yeah it was a snake it was on
flexing all over that's flexing all over
the earth it's okay it was me it was a
real snake now it's a hat yeah